carolin weiter warum alter mann hatte
keinen helm
wow hey leute was klappt herzlich
willkommen beim neuen video
ich habe immer wieder den leser dabei
wir haben ja letztens schon mal ein
video zusammen gedreht
bei mir kam es so vor zwei wochen dies
versuchen nicht zu lachen dings mäßig
das ist voll abgegangen da wir uns
gleich machen waren zweiten teil
heute macht man es aber auch richtig
zusammen also zu zweit weil alleine ist
ein bisschen komisch so irgendwie habe
ich ja damals alleinige macht vor zwei
wochen damals ja wir wollen ja nicht nur
gelaber anfangen kann weil es euch
gefällt dass auf jeden fall noch nach
oben da wollte geht es um it girls fans
compilation wird sagen wir ihnen auf dem
channel gibt es halt noch einen teil
davon also das ganz oben in der video
bestimmen genau zweiter teil zwei leute
wir haben hier nur diese fetten
kopfhörer damit wir das gut hören und
ihr nicht gestört wird also sonst wären
sind sehr groß so super stylisch und
schüsse der trend fashion week fashion
profi 321 letzte okay es geht jetzt mal
hier
er ist ein kompletter nachfahren das
heißt gut geld compilation was hat mein
motor ist garnicht sekunden ist das
gehörte konnte gesagt müssen deutsche
die flosse daun
oder einfach nicht aus
das gilt bei ihren märkten mitarbeiter
ein zeugnis rote tomaten man in unserer
keramischen jugendhaus politische
personal
[Applaus]
ich muss mich also es ist schon ziemlich
lustig dass du angst in die hose sollte
also sie sind youtube fans nicht so
witzig wir gehen jetzt über zu einem
richtigen feld compilation deswegen tut
mir leid die wegen den titel jetzt hier
da sieht man mal wieder wie youtube war
gesagt passt auch oder dass fußball wird
immer gesagt hast auch du bist clicker
das ist vielleicht auch gerade ein
bisschen clique aber okay wir jetzt kann
ich eigentlich youtube feiert gehört
fällt sondern ich scheiß drauf ihr macht
jetzt wird der blick fällt weiter wenn
ihr sagt über das war jetzt blöd dann
schreibst du die kommentare aber ich
mich nicht ganz ehrlich ich weiß was die
haben es drauf die haben es drauf von 14
spielen jungs ist das so
scheiße auf die pizza jugendliche
anhänger junge team mit dem skateboard
alter hätten weiter warum alter mann hat
warum das feld nicht lustig so
richtig
aber ich habe auch schon mal fast ein
reh überfahren ja also etwas gegen
gefahren sagt alter vater nicht unter
marisa bock drauf alter nicht auch von
mir ich hatte soviel erstmal dazu wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann hat euch
gefallen
dann schreib doch mal in die kommentare
wer war besser werden weniger gelacht
schreibe es in die kommentare jetzt
unter allen in die kommentare schreiben
verlor sich hier um nicht so weit will
man messen videos letztendlich haben wir
das einbinden übrigens dass jacobs video
verlinkt das also wenn der videos
verlinkt geht auf seinen palast gerne
aber wenn ihr wollt da kommen jetzt auch
coole sachen denn wenn du mal weiter
nach weniger ich deswegen arbeiten und
kommen auf jeden fall kommen videos
kommen sachen es kommt kommt geigers tag
also soviel sei bereits so viel und am
21 fünfter kommt man 300 tausend
abonnenten special
das wird super deswegen sei geschafft
gefilmt das films wirtschaftlich
gesperrt
das ist geil wir sehen uns morgen kommt
das nächste video morgen 18 uhr seid
dabei die schau